hey mama i'm actually busy right now can
i call you back a little bit later
what hey are you doing
james charles just tried to prank the
kardashians with the tick tock callback
challenge
but kim kardashian wasn't having any of
it
you just gotta roll with it on wednesday
the beauty youtuber shared
the viral tick tock prank on instagram
writing in the caption
quote calling people and telling them
i'm too busy to talk
yeah and that's exactly what he did
starting
with kris jenner hey mom i'm actually
busy right now can i call you back a
little bit later
what i'm i'm busy right now can i call
you back a little bit later
you're busy yeah i'm busy being famous i
have to call you back okay love you bye
and while the famous momma juror seemed
totally confused
kim knew what was up
hey what scam are you doing right now
you're so annoying yeah there's no
fooling kimberly
which i'm so excited about but kim and
chris weren't the only friends of the 21
year old influencer to receive the
prank call oh it's so fun james also hit
up lil na's ex
hey i'm um in the middle of filming a
video right now can i call you back
later
you called me then there was madison
beer
hi gorgeous hey babe i'm busy right now
can i call you back later
george and bibi rexa
hi hey i'm actually really busy right
now can i call you later wait hold on
look at my versace
i have to go i'm busy i'm busy is anyone
else having rolodex envy
do the kids today even know what a
rolodex is
like kim chris bibi madison anyway
james also gave his pal jojo siwa a ring
what's happening hey i'm actually busy
right now can i call you back later
you called me and then there was iggy
azalea who found the whole thing
super funny hey hey i'm super busy right
now can i call you later
yeah okay bye
okay but detective kim is still my
favorite part of this call
hey
you're so annoying of course the
kardashians know
all about a prank phone call
first i had to make sure it was real
what is happening what's going on
back in december chloe kim courtney
kylie chris
and kendall got together put on some
seriously intimidating faces
and face time to their famous friends i
was like
crying laughing without saying a word
just spontaneous just something fun
yeah that's chloe's boyfriend tristan
thompson
stormy's dad travis scott who legit just
peaced out what's going on
bye addison ray was hella confused
hi and dave chappelle was a
whole damn mood
oh my gosh that's the best one then
there was the beavers
justin and haley
hey guys this is
what is happening
hello and kardashian superfan
jennifer lawrence
first i had to make sure it was real
the famous fam even got james charles
who was
confused af
what is going on looks like james got
his payback with chris
but kim remains undefeated hey
what tick-tock scam are you doing
you